men over perceive the level of
attraction that they believe women have
toward them and women under perceive the
level of attraction that men have toward
them referred to as a failure of cross-
seex mind reading and this shows up very
reliably in the data this is why a boss
or a coworker will maybe make an
ungainly move apart from like the creeps
because they will believe that her eyes
always linger on me she always makes it
to the water cooler at the same time
that I do maybe I should try and ask her
out it is much more useful for men to
have a smoke alarm that goes off a lot
and is wrong a lot because the price of
missing a potential signal is really
high and the cost of noticing a signal
that wasn't there is essentially zero
they put men and women down at a speed
dating event asked both of them how
attracted were you to the other one
women regularly rated that they were way
less attracted to the man than the man
thought and the reverse TR to is why men
and women don't understand each other
because we do not have the same brains
and we don't see the world in the same
way